[Musique]
bienvenue ravi de vous retrouver Paris
sa clé TV vous dit tout sur Le Texier ou
quand la technologie fusionne avec le
tertiaire des bâtiments innovants avec
des bureaux et des laboratoires
high-tech on y pense on y réfléchit on
est expérimente la médecine de demain
l'alimentation du futur est bien
d'autres choses encore alors certains
sont encore des projets comme le central
qui va être mené par Sogeprom c'est la
filière immobilière de la Société
Générale et d'autres existent déjà comme
cette incubateur spartner ce qui a été
lancé par le groupe Servier voilà qui
prouve une nouvelle fois le dynamisme et
l'attractivité de votre territoire et
enfin notre agenda ce sera la fin de
cette émission
avoir des bureaux et les laboratoires
qui vont avec l'immobilier Texier se
développent sur votre territoire le
central est un projet qui va se faire
ici il est mené par Sogeprom c'est la
filiale immobilière de la Société
Générale un projet de plus de 60 000 m²
du texiaire donc mais aussi des
logements et des commerces nous avons
rencontré Guillaume python directeur
tertiaire et grands projets
Île-de-France de sogetprome
Sogeprom c'est la filiale de promotion
immobilière du groupe Société Générale
elle compte environ aujourd'hui 325
collaborateurs pour un chiffre
d'affaires d'environ 750 millions
d'euros alors EDF filiale d'une banque
c'est d'abord évidemment une solidité
financière pour le promoteur que nous
sommes mais c'est également la
possibilité de s'asseoir sur des
engagements RSE forts qui sont portés
par le groupe et ça à travers notre
raison d'être et également notre
engagement à travers le pacte 3B un
engagement donc bas carbone un
engagement sur la biodiversité et un
engagement sur le bien-vivre les raisons
de notre engagement sur les territoires
de Paris Saclay sont les suivantes c'est
que nous sommes convaincus par
l'attractivité économique par le
dynamisme que représente aujourd'hui ce
territoire enfin l'arrivée dès 2026 de
la ligne 18 du métro du Grand Paris
Express sera un élément clé de
l'attractivité de ce territoire
le central est un projet que nous
développons en copro-motion avec nos
partenaires de Mathieu hey bar
immobilier qui est mandataire notre
groupement et également pitch promotion
c'est plus de 60 000 mètres carrés d'un
projet mixte de logements de commerce et
d'activités
c'est la contraction de technologie et
tertiaire ce sont donc des immeubles qui
vont s'adresser à des entreprises de la
tech qui ont besoin de bureaux mais
aussi de laboratoire pour développer
leur activité
alors pour les copropromoteurs le
central c'est évidemment un partage de
conviction un partage de conviction
d'abord sur l'attractivité du territoire
et un partage de conviction sur
l'immeuble textière que l'on va aider
l'enjeu étant d'attirer et de pérenniser
l'installation de start-up sur le
territoire de Paris Saclay
nous avons donc travaillé avec l'agence
baume Schlager et Burley qui a déjà
travaillé ce type de produit également
le bureau d'études ingrope qui a de
nombreuses références sur ce type
d'actif et afin de pouvoir appréhender
au mieux les besoins des futurs
utilisateurs et dimensionner l'immeuble
au plus près nous avons choisi nous
entourer de l'AMO helix qui a d'ores et
déjà pu dimensionner pour nous les
espaces de laboratoire les espaces
dédiés à la chimie à des niveaux de
confinement un peu différents pour
pouvoir répondre à peu près à toutes les
demandes du secteur le projet Texier sur
le central se développera en deux
tranches une première tranche de 6000 m²
pour une livraison à horizon 2025 et une
deuxième tranche de 10 000 mètres carrés
pour une livraison à horizon 2026
[Musique]
parmi les autres grands chantiers à
venir cadence sciences Partners va
développer 14000 m² d'offre textières
destinées à la diptex ce sera ici
toujours dans le quartier de Moulon
alors la dictée ce sont ces startups qui
proposent des produits innovants basés
sur le numérique et pour cette opérateur
mondialement connu et bien c'était une
évidence de s'installer ici sur votre
territoire
cadence sciences Partners c'est une
société européenne
et depuis plus de 20 ans nous concevons
construisons et exploitons des bâtiments
et campus dédiés aux entreprises et
organisations innovantes des secteurs
des sciences du vivant et des
technologies à Paris Saclay est plus
précisément dans la ZAC du Moulon sur la
commune de Gif-sur-Yvette nous sommes en
train de concevoir avec le PA Paris
Saclay un bâtiment qui fera environ
14000 m² entièrement dédié aux sociétés
et organisations du plateau pour y
accueillir à peu près 60% de
laboratoires et les bureaux associés et
soutenir les startups les skylobs les
PME et même les grands groupes du
plateau sur des secteurs de la santé
agro et également tout ce qui concerne
la clean tech la greetech notamment qui
exprime des besoins en termes de
laboratoire bsl2 et espace de
bioproduction
la conception du bâtiment est faite par
la agence d'architecture charte et
d'Alix que nous avons retenu à l'issue
d'un concours avec une conception très
modulaire à la fois dans son plan masse
dans son architecture puisqu'elle est
conçue autour de 4 plots qui sont reliés
par un atrium central et des espaces
communs généreux et au sein des espaces
privatifs de laboratoire et de bureau on
prévoyons une grande modularité entre le
laboratoire et le bureau pour offrir les
deux types de surfaces des 50 mètres
carrés et jusqu'à plusieurs milliers la
conception la construction et
l'exploitation du bâtiment s'inscriront
dans une démarche environnementale très
ambitieuse avec une attention à la
consommation de carbone selon les futurs
réglementations environnementales et
revint RER 25 le choix de la pierre
comme matériaux de façade a été très
naturel tant pour l'architecte que pour
le PA et cadence et la municipalité dans
son choix puisque
c'est un matériau qui est bas carbone
qui viendra de la région et qui sera
très pérenne dans dans le temps par
ailleurs il y aura une production sur
site de d'électricité avec des panneaux
photovoltaïques en toiture
donc l'ouverture du bâtiment pour les
futurs occupants est prévue en 2026 qui
devrait accompagner la livraison du
l'ouverture du de la ligne de métro qui
arrive à quelques mètres de l'immeuble
et maintenant un exemple très concret
nous sommes dans le quartier de Moulon
le groupe Servier lance l'incubateur
spartner en partenariat avec biolabs un
incubateur dédié au sens du vivant à
savoir faire venu des États-Unis tout de
suite les explications de Philippe Godon
le directeur du site
c'est une société qui est née aux
États-Unis à Boston et dont le but
premier était de donner la possibilité à
des startups de biotechnologie d'accéder
à des locaux des laboratoires tout
équipé et d'avoir accès également au
service qui vient avec afin de pouvoir
leur permettre de se focaliser sur le
développement de leur science nous avons
une offre qui est vraiment dédiée aux
sociétés des sciences du vivant en leur
offrant à la fois des espaces de
laboratoire qu'ils soient commun ou
privés et des espaces tertiaires encore
une fois qu'ils soient commun ou privés
en plus de cette offre relativement
innovante nous amenons un service qui
est complet un service qui va
correspondre par exemple à la gestion
des laboratoires à la formation des
techniciens à l'utilisation de certains
équipements au respect des règles de
biosécurité puisque nous avons des
laboratoires de confinement L1 et L2
mais également à la création de ce que
l'on appelle la communauté donc essayer
de mettre en œuvre un réseau le réseau
des entrepreneurs de biotechnologie au
niveau local au niveau national européen
évidemment avec nos partenaires
américains au niveau global l'idée c'est
que cette communauté puisse s'enrichir
d'elle-même au travers des différentes
expériences qu'elle a vécues mais
également accéder à des fonds puisque
c'est l'honneur de la guerre en
biotechnologie et pour arriver à lever
ses fonds il faut démontrer que l'on
sait dérisqué la phase la plus
dangereuse dans le développement d'un
médicament ou d'un service c'est la
phase de R&D et c'est exactement ce que
nous amenons une accélération du time to
market à ses entreprises en faisant en
sorte de dérisquer tout ce qui est de
phase de R&D puisque ils n'ont pas
besoin d'acheter des locaux du matériel
ou d'embaucher des responsables hygiène
et sécurité par exemple alors le choix
qu'a fait servié en venant installer
l'ensemble de ces centres rédés sur le
territoire Paris-Saclay n'est pas anodin
comme vous pouvez l'imaginer on va y
trouver l'ensemble des
ce qu'on qualifie de dur qui sont
aujourd'hui tout à fait nécessaires
notamment en informatique en bio
informatique en ingénierie également
pour tout ce qui est médical device et
on est surtout dans une phase
d'ébullition en termes d'innovation et
je crois que un acteur de la pharmacie
comme Servier est absolument utile pour
assurer la complétude en terme de
compétences du plateau de Saclay et ce
dynamisme la richesse de ses étudiants
et ses entrepreneurs fait que installer
un incubateur biotech sur ce territoire
là a tout à fait son sens ce que nous
souhaitons c'est cristalliser vraiment
cette univers de l'élévation en biais
technologique sur le plateau de Saclay
au travers de l'existence de spartners
by servianbals nous organisons très
régulièrement des visites et des
présentations de cette incubateur qui
ouvrira à l'horizon du 1er juin nous
avons déjà sélectionné deux entreprises
d'ici le mois de avril deux nouvelles
seront sélectionnés et ainsi de suite
tous les mois ou tous les deux mois donc
n'hésitez pas à prendre contact pour ne
serait-ce qu'avoir une petite vision de
ce que peut offrir ce Partners et nous
vous présenterons avec plaisir nos
différents sites
je vous emmène à présent au food in Lab
à laboratoire ou plutôt une cuisine
expérimentale alors le lieu se trouve à
AgroParisTech une grande école dont on
vous a beaucoup parlé de jeunes
chercheurs réfléchissent à
l'alimentation de demain et ils peuvent
donc faire des tests grandeur nature
c'est un lieu innovant nous avons
rencontré à la responsable Salomé Falise
[Musique]
le foodynabs c'est une structure qui
accompagne des entrepreneurs qui veulent
innover dans l'alimentaire on les
accompagne de deux manières la première
c'est en leur mettant à disposition des
équipements donc une cuisine
expérimentale des laboratoires et tout
un banc d'équipements professionnels
pour avancer dans leur test et la
deuxième manière de les accompagner
c'est de les mettre en relation avec
tous l'écosystème d'AgroParisTech donc
d'une part les étudiants avec des
projets notamment étudiants et d'autre
part avec tous les experts qu'on peut
trouver dans les unités de recherche
d'AgroParisTech
[Musique]
typiquement ici on est dans une cuisine
expérimentale c'est un des lieux dans
lesquels les startups peuvent venir
travailler leurs produits faire leurs
recherches et développement
le food in Lab on accompagne des projets
très variés qui touchent à
l'alimentation durable ça peut être des
projets qui travaillent des alternatives
à la viande ou des nouvelles protéines
donc des algues des insectes des
légumineuses ce genre de produits ça
peut être aussi le développement de
nouveaux aliments à partir de co-produit
donc des anciens déchets qui jusqu'à
maintenant étaient pas utilisés et qui
sont valorisés pour des nouveaux
ingrédients
[Musique]
les entrepreneurs qu'on accompagne ici
sont au tout début de leur aventure
entrepreneuriale donc ils sont vraiment
un moment où ils vont faire des tests
pour trouver leur innovation développer
leur premier prototypes ensuite il y a
toute une phase de recherche et de ce
qu'elle up pour monter à l'échelle et
pouvoir produire en quantité suffisante
pour commercialiser mais déjà à la
sortie du food in Lab ils sont en
capacité de faire des premières
productions et de vendre et puis les
réseaux de distribution dépendront des
produits ça peut être un e-commerce ça
peut être dans de la grande distrib ça
peut être dans des magasins spécialisés
en B2B etc
aujourd'hui l'avantage du footing là par
rapport à d'autres cuisines
expérimentales qu'on peut trouver dans
Paris par exemple c'est d'être connecté
à tous l'écosystème d'AgroParisTech et
de pouvoir solliciter ces expertises et
maintenant qu'on est implanté sur le
plateau de Saclay c'est encore plus de
réseau de partenaires et d'expertise qui
peuvent solliciter facilement
[Musique]
notre agenda à présent avec bien sûr le
rendez-vous à ne pas rater la date
approche le 1er juin c'est le pari sa
clé spring c'est à HEC les inscriptions
sont ouvertes après il y en a pour tous
les goûts si vous aimez le sport la
course du printemps c'est ce dimanche 2
avril pour les petits et les grands
c'est un voisin le Bretonneux vous avez
envie de cultures violettes et une fable
dystopique un opéra de la compagnie
l'aurore boréale Jacques auzinski c'est
du mercredi 19 au vendredi 21 avril à
l'École normale supérieure de Paris
Saclay et enfin si vous aimez le grand
air la nature les oiseaux une visite de
l'observatoire ornithologique de Saclay
est prévue le 22 avril dans la zénaf et
voilà c'est déjà la fin de cette
émission merci de votre fidélité on se
retrouve très vite pour un nouveau
numéro de Paris Saclay TV
[Musique]